[Musique]
je m'appelle Sony j'ai 25 ans ça fait 5
ans que je suis à Disney à l'hôtel
c'est comme cuisine
tout à l'heure et après au niveau des
desserts plus de 300 assiettes ok ça
marche beaucoup de travail aujourd'hui
elle héritier beaucoup beaucoup intense
et c'est pour ça dès le matin qu'on
arrive on est motivé direct comme ça on
sait que qu'on a terminé on a terminé si
on attend pas derrière après le soir il
y aura de la percussion
à leur tempérament oui il a il s'est le
garder tranquille il est là pour bosser
j'ai fait le service militaire
volontaire à Brétigny-sur-Orge dans le
j'ai fait pendant 6 mois voilà j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses que ce soit
motivation se réveiller tôt apprendre
que faut se battre dans la vie pour
avoir quelque chose si tu veux un truc
comme tout ça le permis ou que ça au
boulot ça peut venir vers toi qui va
chercher c'est comme être cher ou pas
pour le chercher
loin toujours bon en fait ça me motive
deux fois plus
de monter de grade et peut-être pourquoi
pas un jour être chef quoi
aujourd'hui Sony est un garçon sérieux
et consciencieux mais tout ne pas été
simple pour lui un peu perdu dans sa
jeunesse il a fait le choix il y a 5 ans
d'intégrer le service militaire
volontaire le SMV
ses efforts et sa motivation lui ont
permis de décrocher un emploi stable au
sein du plus grand parc d'attraction
d'Europe
une des volontés de Disneyland Paris
c'est de s'intéresser à ceux qui ont des
profils peut-être un petit peu
différents des autres qui ont peut-être
un petit peu moins de chance et de leur
donner justement une chance donc bien
évidemment quand on est sur un programme
comme celui du service militaire où il y
a un réel accompagnement une réelle
volonté de donner ensuite aux jeunes non
seulement un emploi mais une situation
pérenne et stable c'est une chance qu'il
saisisse et c'est ce qui est intéressant
pour nous c'est grâce à eux le service
militaire volontaire à Disney que je
suis ici aujourd'hui que j'ai mon CDI
que ça fait cinq ans que je progresse
chaque jour en jour que voilà
[Musique]
elle
est encore Joris en manque de
perspective décrocheur scolaire pour
certains ils ont choisi comme Sony avant
eux de prendre leur destin en main ils
font partie des 7000 volontaires
âgés de 16 à 25 ans qui chaque année
pousse la Porte du service militaire
adapté en outre-mer et du service
militaire volontaire en métropole
symbole de l'engagement des armées en
faveur de l'insertion
socioprofessionnelle ces deux
dispositifs n'ont pas vocation à venir
gonfler les rangs des armées mais bien
d'offrir un horizon à ces jeunes
volontaires en manque de repères
en intégrant le SMA ou le SMV ils
apprennent les rudiments de la vie en
communauté dans un cadre militaire
bénéficie de remise à niveau passe leur
permis de conduire et acquiert des
qualifications professionnelles et ce
dans tous les domaines plus de 70%
d'entre eux trouve un emploi durable
après leur année de formation un
tremplin pour ces jeunes volontaires
pour l'emploi
[Musique]
au coeur de l'océan Indien l'île de la
Réunion accueille le plus important
régiment du service militaire adapté
[Musique]
chaque année près de 1400 réunionnais
éloignés de l'école viennent ici pour
apprendre à réussir
je m'appelle Jean-Philippe j'ai 19 ans
j'ai intégré le RSMA le 31 août ça va
faire bientôt un mois dans une semaine
[Musique]
depuis 3 semaines c'est jeune
réunionnais ont appris à vivre un rythme
bien particulier
réveille aux aurores vit en collectivité
ils ont découvert dans un cadre
militaire la topographie le secourisme
les liaisons radio
malgré les apparences le but n'est pas
de faire de ces jeunes des militaires
ces premiers pas sous l'uniformes ont
pour vocation d'apprendre le vivre
ensemble à ces jeunes en difficulté moi
j'ai appris la cohésion ce qui est très
important ici la cohésion c'est un effet
de groupe c'est de savoir aussi diriger
un groupe orienter un groupe prendre
être le pot de parole aussi c'est très
très important savoir être là pour tout
le monde être à l'écoute
ça fait que j'ai plus de responsabilités
sur mon dos parce que si je me trompe
je peux fausser tout toute l'équipe et
du coup bah c'est à moi de bien vérifier
les choses et si jamais je ne comprends
pas ou si je me trompe l'équipe doit
aussi m'aider du coup je vais aussi
apprendre à écouter les autres
et apprendre tout en compte ok
quels sont les symptômes qui coût de
chaleur aujourd'hui ils devront marcher
10 km et synthétiser ce qu'ils ont
appris
ces premiers pas en Rangers constituent
la première étape d'un parcours qui va
durer presque un an à la clé une
formation professionnelle et un emploi
le but c'est de voilà de décrocher un
emploi d'avoir des connaissances
approfondies qui ont beaucoup m'aider et
le fait de passer au SMS ça donne un
coup de pouce parce que les patrons
savent que souvent les personnes qui
sont pas sourires SMA sont ponctuelles
sont organisés sont souvent perspicaces
c'est anticipé les choses et aussi
exécuter des tâches et du coup bah le
fait d'aller au récemment c'est pas
comme l'école le RSA ils sont là à nos
côtés nous accompagnent ils nous donnent
des tâches à exécuter il nous est à
progresser et à nous pousser
fatigué mais heureux cet ensemble qu'ils
ont été au bout de cette marche
collective qui clôt un mois
d'apprentissage de la vie militaire
de là c'est la fin du parcours comment
tu te sens ça y est un peu fatigué mais
toujours présent ça va on est là on est
pressé de rentrer pour manger aucune
difficulté et du coup
fier de l'avoir fait ok
pour le moment c'est bon
ah c'est bien les gars
il faut réintégrer les équipements
mais la journée n'est pas encore
terminée pour cette jeune promotion de
volontaire réunionnais
ils doivent à présent se tenir prêt pour
une étape aussi importante que
symbolique la présentation au drapeau
une cérémonie qui marque la fin de la
formation militaire initiale
[Musique]
ce terrain ici même à cet emplacement
vous serez rassemblés en compagnie comme
ceci donc là ce qu'on va vous demander
si vous de vous éparpiller et dans la
foulée vous allez vous rassembler en
compagnie
importante oui ça va marquer la fin de
leur formation de un mois c'est ça
j'imagine je pense bien que oui tout
soit parfait oui il vaut mieux être
parfait grâce à vous il faut parfait en
espérant que ça va marcher oui
compagnie garde à vous
c'est le drapeau du régiment du service
militaire adapté de la Réunion
les drapeaux du
des RSMA ont une particularité ce qu'ils
sont les seuls drapeaux de l'armée de
terre à avoir sur leur plie le nom de la
région
au profit de laquelle il s'engage voilà
la Réunion et ça c'est cet ancrage
territorial au profit des Outre-mer
c'est vraiment une particularité des
régiments du service militaire adapté
tu changes de tenue pour présider la
cérémonie de présentation au drapeau des
jeunes volontaires la présentation de
drapeau c'est l'entrée dans la famille
du service militaire adapté c'est
environ 1400 jeunes tous les ans c'est
près de 11% d'une classe d'âge de jeunes
Réunionnais réunionnaise et donc depuis
56 ans ça fait en fait 47000 jeunes
Réunionnais notre taux d'insertion et de
l'ordre de 80% ce qui est un résultat
remarquable
considéré comme l'un des plus méritants
Jean-Philippe reçoit l'insigne du
régiment du service militaire adapté de
la réunion des mains du chef de corps
désormais il pourra la porter fièrement
pour Jean-Philippe c'est beaucoup
d'espoir aussi
maintenant au régiment du RSMA c'est
officiel c'est là voilà c'est parti on
se lance et c'est le grand saut
un grand saut qui va encore durer
quelques mois Jean-Philippe va intégrer
une section de formation professionnelle
pour devenir peintre en bâtiment
il bénéficiera d'une formation
complémentaire du dispensant une remise
à niveau en français des tests de
compréhension ou encore une
sensibilisation numérique un
accompagnement personnalisé quand j'ai
lu est en train de suivre
je m'appelle angélique j'ai 18 ans je
suis d'origine lyonnaise j'ai connu le
soma par rapport aux réseaux sociaux et
mes amis et vu que j'aimais pas beaucoup
l'école et puis dirigez ici ça m'a plu
quand il y avait la demande que je
voulais faire l'électricité vérifier ses
gants
vérifier son casque
qui me plaît les sociétés de courant et
je sais que si demain matin ben j'ai une
maison je peux compter que sur moi pour
l'électricité la seule chose que j'aime
cela fait deux mois quand j'ai lu qui a
poussé la porte du régiment du service
militaire adapté de la réunion après
avoir accompli sa formation militaire
initiale comme Jean-Philippe elle a
député sa formation professionnelle en
tant qu’électricienne du bâtiment
aujourd'hui elle passe son habilitation
électrique un examen essentiel pour
l'exercice de son futur métier elle peut
compter sur l'expérience du caporal chez
François
ce jeune polynésien était il y a 8 ans à
la place d'Angélique ancien volontaire
stagiaire il a voulu aller plus loin et
intégrer le RSMA en tant que formateur
pour transmettre son savoir et sa
passion
donc dépannage il réussit ok aujourd'hui
quand je vois un volonté stagiaire de ma
section ou même dans la compagnie dans
le régiment donc ça me fait penser les
premiers jours où j'ai mis les pieds au
RSMA pour une innésie Française la
plupart du temps reçoit des volonté
stagiaires qui sortent d'un milieu
paiement défavorisé moi ce que je
souhaite à tous les stagiaires c'est de
réussir dans un projet professionnel
qu'il a permis d'avancer dans la vie
active
la mobilité le matin autonome
une vie d'actif c'est tout de suite on
a plus le temps de réfléchir c'est
maintenant
par la tête ça rentre par le bras comme
un chef et c'est bien parce que dans la
vie de tous les jours quand on va avoir
un métier ce sera pareil c'est quelque
chose de bien ça fait du bien
entre vie en collectivité séance de
sport et apprentissage des cours de
remise à niveau prépare ses jeunes
volontaires stagiaires à comprendre par
exemple le contenu d'un contrat de
travail ou bien écrire une lettre de
motivation tout concours a trouvé un
emploi
avec moi on va faire du français on va
faire de la lecture donc de la
compréhension de texte implicie
explicite
avec les électriciens et aujourd'hui on
fait des cours de remise à niveau donc
de maths français avec les stagiaires on
doit faire 150 heures de cours pour
qu'ils aient les CFG la certification de
formation générale en fait c'est tout
simplement l'équivalent du brevet en
fait c'est un diplôme qui permet de
prouver qui connaissent les bases en
fait le mot clé est entouré la phase du
texte c'est un peu difficile au début
mais ça va ça va pas prendre quoi pour
plus tard ça a des papiers faire un CV
surtout il y a beaucoup de Français de
maths et dans le domaine de
l'électricité on va faire
mathématiques aussi et tout ça c'est
essentiel pour toi
c'est important dans la vie de tous les
jours oui si le service militaire adapté
de la Réunion en deux mois déjà apporté
beaucoup pas angélique il lui faudra
encore s'investir pendant 8 mois pour
obtenir sa certification professionnelle
mais avant cela le SMA lui fera passer
son permis de conduire un sésame souvent
indispensable pour décrocher un emploi
passer gratuitement son permis de
conduire c'est en partie ce qui a
convaincu Hugo en métropole il a fait le
choix du service militaire volontaire
j'ai 21 ans je viens de Saint-Brieuc en
Bretagne j'ai intégré le service
militaire volontaire il y a bientôt 5
mois c'est un bon centre de formation
il y a beaucoup de choses à apprendre et
en plus le permis qui est compris dans
la formation donc il y a que du bon je
vais avoir le permis de conduire ça pas
que à moi ça sert à tout le monde c'est
dans la vie de tous les jours que ce
soit professionnel parlant ou même
personnellement et c'est gratuit c'est
compris dans la formation donc pour ceux
qui ont pas trop les moyens de se payer
le permis il faut foncer
écoutez bien en cours et appliquer ce
qu'on vous dit ça sert à rien de
stresser
originaire de Bretagne Hugo est présent
avec sa section au premier régiment du
service militaire volontaire de
Montigny-lès-Metz depuis déjà deux
semaines au programme un accompagnement
intensif pour réussir le Code de la
route et obtenir le permis de conduire
dans le véhicule
en plus on a de la chance il fait beau
donc là on voit que le feu vient de
passer au rouge donc on va pouvoir y
aller
chevauche bien
ok l'espoir venir le volant tu
l'accompagnes à chaque fois d'accord on
chauffe dans un sens et ensuite on
chevauche dans l'autre
première fois que je suis rentré dans la
voiture je savais pas du tout conduire
en fait
et je savais pas passer une vitesse rien
et maintenant je suis plutôt à l'aise on
va dire le prochain feu on ira à droite
d'accord c'est quand même accéder à une
certaine liberté d'avoir son permis de
conduire donc essayer de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour que ces jeunes puissent
décrocher le sésame voilà c'est c'est un
moment important on a pas mal évolué
grâce aux moniteurs qui se démène tous
les jours pour nous faire évoluer donc
franchement je me sens très bien là
attention avec cette confiance au volant
quand même on fait toujours attention
ok très bien
quand on est droit on redresse s'adresse
et on coupe ok bah c'était bien OK
après plus de 20 heures de conduite Hugo
se présentera au permis de conduire mais
avant cela il doit réussir son examen de
code de la route
ce code de la route il l'a passé il y a
déjà quelques jours et aujourd'hui c'est
le jour des résultats
donc voilà donc là on arrive sur la fin
les tests d'examens de code
examen de conduite c'est demain
donc là je vais vous donner vos
résultats en code Hugo
[Applaudissements]
à Saint-Denis
pour les réussites félicitations à vous
à chacun vous savez que vous allez
travailler pendant trois semaines et
aujourd'hui vous en êtes là vous avez
votre code donc félicitations à vous
comment tu te sens très bien
tout donner demain pour la conduite
tu m'envoies une vidéo
une fois
encore
évolué grâce au service militaire
volontaire du coup j'ai pu prendre de la
confiance en moi savoir me gérer
moi-même le service militaire c'est un
très bon centre de formation bonjour Le
Journal de la défense ça y est j'ai
obtenu le permis grâce au SMV super
content et maintenant on est prêt pour
la suite
permis en poche Hugo reprendra la route
pour Brest
passion de mécanicien d'autres jeunes
vont bientôt achever leur formation
professionnelle au service militaire
volontaire c'est le cas de Joris après 7
mois au SMV il se destine à devenir
vendeur spécialisé je m'appelle Joris
j'ai 22 ans et je suis actuellement au
service militaire volontaire de
Châlons-en-Champagne je l'ai intégré le
23 mars 2021
termine mon incorporation dans à peu
près un mois avec un objectif de
décrocher un boulot
j'étais dans une hygiène de vie où on
est jeune donc on a envie de s'amuser on
a envie de faire la fête sauf que pour
faire tout ça il faut forcer bon bien
gagner sa vie moi j'avais envie d'un peu
de rigueur un peu tout ça pour pouvoir
évoluer dans dans ma vie professionnelle
pour soi même aussi c'est mieux parce
que on se réveille on fait son lit moi
le soir on rentre on voit que notre lit
il est propre on dort pas dans un lit et
tout défait ça un peu du mieux vivre
ensemble ça prend beaucoup de choses
donc
et le refaire chez toi après tu vois ça
va faire 8 mois que je le fais donc à
force et tout ça va tout seul donc
rendez-vous Place d'Armes à 6h15 donc
pour ensuite aller manger à l'ordinaire
c'est comme ça tous les matins
pour valider sa formation Joris doit
effectuer un stage en entreprise de 15
jours pour se confronter au terrain et
surtout valider ses compétences pour
garder le cap il sait pouvoir compter
sur le briller des chefs Michael le
cadre de sa section qu'il accompagne
depuis le début de son aventure avec le
service militaire volontaire tous les
matins on la compagne on va avec lui on
demande contre la journée s'est passée
on va on lâche pas on est toujours avec
lui toujours le rassurer voilà la
compagnie dans ces dans sa vie future
le respect voyagef
vous allez bien
la motivation la rigueur
même si je sais qu'à travers le masque
on voit pas forcément bien sûr il faut
quand même voilà montrer qu'on a envie
[Musique]
donc là nous allons sur stage là donc à
Kiabi c'est à Saint mémé là c'est à 10
minutes d'ici voilà on emmène Joris le
matin à son stage
[Musique]
bonjour
c'est seulement son deuxième jour de
stage mais Joris semble déjà avoir pris
ses marques
programme de la journée mis sur Centre
préparation de commandes et relations
avec la clientèle bonjour
avec les filles on a bien rigolé bien
bossé donc tout devrait aller
alors là je commence à dépoter ce matin
en livraison et ensuite je fais de la
cabine
toujours voilà à l'écoute
bonne journée Joris
au revoir
j'ai choisi cette formation parce que
déjà le texte lit ça me plaît beaucoup
donc et puis on est dans un monde où
maintenant la mode est très très
populaire donc
être bien sur soi était c'est important
alors mais on nous l'apprend aussi à
bien nous habiller c'est peut-être
quelque chose de nul mais au final non
parce que ça c'est important
en fait nous on les stagiaires sont
toujours en binôme on les laisse jamais
tout seul parce qu'on est là pour leur
apprendre et le problème c'est que je
risque de laisser un peu seul parce
qu'en fait on voit qu'il est mature et
que bah il est à l'aise en fait donc
voilà mais c'est vraiment la première
fois sur le SMV c'est une très belle une
très belle surprise enfin je suis
surprise de voir qu'il est vraiment
au top quoi et on pense pas qu'en fait
une personne qui vient du service
militaire entre guillemets et cette
attitude là et c'est peut-être pas ce
qu'il veut faire plus tard mais en tout
cas il a une attitude certes sur un
travail d'équipe moi quand je suis
arrivé hier
je pensais qu'il est ça faisait
longtemps qu'il était là j'ai trouvé
vraiment très à l'aise il a fait tout de
suite une commande avec une cliente il
ne savait pas faire mais il a réussi à
faire il est quand même il cherche c'est
pour ça que moi je vous le dis quand je
l'ai vu pour moi ça faisait déjà
plusieurs semaines qu'il était chez nous
donc non c'est bien bonjour monsieur
vous voulez essayer
je vous laisserai juste vous laver les
mains j'ai grandi aussi dans ma tête en
un an j'ai vu que j'ai fait beaucoup
plus que ce que j'ai fait en deux trois
ans de ma vie d'avant donc voilà
au terme de 8 mois de formation je
risque obtiendra son certificat
d'aptitude personnel à l'emploi et
pourra entrer sur le marché du travail
de manière durable comme plus de 70% des
volontaires avant lui
après 60 ans d'existence pour le service
militaire adapté en outre-mer et six
années pour le service militaire
volontaire en métropole c'est plus de
125 000 jeunes éloignés de l'emploi qui
ont eu recours à ces deux dispositifs
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle
réparties sur 7 territoires d'outre-mer
et 730 métropole
125000 jeunes en manque de repères qui
ont surtout retrouvé estime et confiance
en eux tous volontaires ils ont appris à
devenir citoyen
que je peux leur dire c'est de foncer
de pas réfléchir qu'à le service
militaire c'est un centre de formation
un très bon centre de formation pensez
faut pas regarder que le matin se
réveille tôt non mais il faut foncer
parce que elle Dogma pour sanitaire
rester encore plus dur de chercher du
boulot alors que là c'est important
c'est une belle expérience de vie ça
change et on apprend beaucoup de choses
en si peu de temps et grâce au SMA aussi
demain matin il pourra avoir un diplôme
et
la recette c'est d'y rentrer pour s'en
sortir
ceux qui sont perdus qui ne savent pas
au niveau scolaire ce qui va faire plus
tard ben tenter lancez-vous le RSMA ça
peut vous sauver vous apprendre les
choses au moins ayez la force le courage
d'essayer qui tendrait à rien
[Musique]